so one situation would be for example if
you heard of ectopic pregnancy yeah yeah
so that's the Fallopian tubes yeah so
the so the kind of the embryo hasn't
made it up to the to the womb to implant
in the womb and it implants into the
fallopian tube and that's dangerous
right it's dangerous women and the
child's not going to survive because it
can't grow and you know and continue to
develop in the fallopian tube so what
will happen is the the baby will die and
the mother will die so what they do
babies should be allowed to die and that
and that is life-saving so the intent of
that is to save life right so it's to
save life if we could well both lives
but I mean sorry to say save the
mother's life sorry so in that situation
you would agree that that would be yeah
and I don't it's not even considered
it's a very different procedure so they
what they do is they go in and they cut
the fallopian tube and take it out so
it's not even what is it won't be in the
abortion status it doesn't classify as
an abortion no because that's
life-saving treatment